an x-ray Korea it's very exciting day
today gamespot offices we arrived in for
work today and what do you know the
pip-boy edition of fallout 4 was waiting
for us so how about we unbox this let's
do it
we've already peeled off the sort of the
stickers that keep this lovely plastic
shell on it yeah so that's nice a nice
plastic shell as well we're gonna say
it's sturdy plastic as plastic shells go
it's quite beautiful add this is the box
that comes in and which has I guess
these two little notches on the side so
let's try thirty gosh I figured it's add
together so you pulled these two guys
back and then and then up oh we go look
at okay here's a steelbook edition of
the video game Fallout 4 and and then
here it is oh my gosh hey boy don't I do
the honors oh man pull it out
it's got like a couple oh wait I thought
it has oh it's all put together already
ooh well that's nothing else in here
there is a stand actually and this looks
like a oh it's for phone rings for your
cat your iPhone
oh very good yes iPhone 5 / 5s use phone
rings iPhone 6 users out of foam ring
only so I guess it's a way of
stabilizing it within the unit so that's
pretty cool so it works for all those
phones if you don't have one of those
update I don't know would you like to do
the oh my gosh dude on c4 fits okay
that's it oh it does feel good actually
is it can we close close this latch oh
my god I love so the latch on it there
as well there's also super fall ready to
cut like and there it is very hefty uh
little dolls on athos move I can change
my radio frequency there if I want and
my rods are currently ash oh I think I
think there are one which is probably
yeah yeah it's within limits maybe and
here's a little switch on it which I
believe is for the when you
the app up there's a power button here
as well and and then this little dude
here clicks between your different it's
a little bit funny how it works actually
this is like a really faithful yeah this
is a I think I think it's slightly
different to the other one because I
believe on fallout 3 and for that the
dial was on the other side maybe so I
guess it's kind of been like you know
ergonomically fixed that it really does
work and no dial up here as well
Sigma is seeping stick a phone in yeah
I've got a case here so I've got an
iPhone 6 so I guess I just need to use
the outer oh wow look at the mall
there's actually quite a lot of like the
covers here oh my god they did like
sizes a lot to have on your arm so you
can hang a phone in there and you can
play this you can use this with the game
yeah so the there is an app coming out
which basically and you access via the
phone which connects up to your console
via so means we don't actually know if
any of that stops available yet right
now we all need to stop the hardware ok
so to pop it open it's down here figured
a - this little battery here better pull
that guy oh boy oh man it just lit up
Oh got it then this is where your phone
goes ok let's see if we can just squeeze
it then it's not my phone's in there
doing nothing right now you ain't got no
app I can call my mom maybe with this
thing on oh you should just wear it like
that and then take all your calls
FaceTime on your boy it's more
comfortable than I think most things in
the wasteland ok there we go alright Wow
how is it I mean I know I'm wearing it
so I'm like Madison keyboards okay I can
rest it here then let it do experience
yeah and if wherever I was on a
controller like little blip yeah I can
see getting pretty it's good a while
yeah but if you don't know where it
comes on this you can put it on this
beautiful stand as well
understand - it looks like wow that's
super nice but there it is right there
as your pip-boy edition of fallout 4 so
actually behind the game we have a
little operation manual so it's right
here so if you're like us and you just
jumped in straight away to use it and if
you have a little bit more patience and
there's all the details here on what
phone-sized is to use how to open up the
unit and and had to get your your phone
working with the software as well so it
actually supports galaxy s3 as well
galaxy s4 s5 but there it is that's your
pip-boy edition of fall f4 so for
continuing coverage a five-four and dome
hardware to buy with your video games
stay tuned to gangster calm